hello everybody and welcome to part 9 of
let's play from dust all right I was in
the middle of damming up this ocean cuz
I'm a badass like that oh yeah get out
of here
ocean no one likes you anyway and now
I'm gonna move these trees cuz I hate
these things
top of them on Boop yep that's right
alright okay your sand I keep picking up
sand oh don't even try it shaking don't
you do nothing
oh they die up here don't I just planned
that one it looks dead alright whatever
come here and oh oh what the hell it's
fallen
oh don't replant yourself Wow what the
hell is going on with that thing
alright this is weird
I'll just drop you in the ocean cuz you
look like some alien creature I don't
even know about
alright whatever okay last one Boop Kyle
may are you alright
right on this animal OOP take that
aminal and finally oh man I can
repopulate this with just one has there
always just been one here man
annoying okay alright now these fires
need to shut up I'll shut up fire group
aha yeah got you
alright now I can finally repopulate
this last one where everyone died like
10 times
oh another one of these things what if
these aren't good creepy cat here but
all right this is another one must be
the dead skeleton of the fire trees they
look like stalkers from half-life 2
don't they not just me
am I going crazy yeah all right this
sounds good
that sounds good vegetation almost at
100% oh yeah cuz I'm in demand all right
now yep
go go my little guys go go old man old
old old lady sorry sorry ma'am
you're obviously a lady all right almost
go go go circle around it go go go Oh
ma'am I do not notice those messages up
in the top those get annoying yay
let me get this water thing out of here
oh yeah boom
cool all right
I wonder what had happen if all my
people died wait can I move this thing
oh I could have moved that a long time
ago somewhere safer that is obviously
not safe guard Claire aah I don't wanna
I don't know leave it I don't want to
I don't wanna oh come on
ex ex cancel okay all right all the
villages are good I think this has
opened up now am I ready is there
anything else I think I've looked over
this island pretty much five times um
looks good let me just add a little sand
so that vegetation can grow I kind of
want to get to 100%
cuz I'm a completionist like that all
right go go
go come on
nope come on
not quite alright maybe that's not
anyway they try right here this might do
it
look video pretty video believe me leave
oh yeah that did it
let's flew some water on it loose loose
loose loose loose loose sploosh
alright this is probably boring you guys
to tears
ah let's go let's go let's get out of
here
salad is cursed yeah alright zest you
send your best able-bodied able-bodied
men and women able-bodied yeah you look
able oh no and the old men you creepy
old guys with the women how weird is
that
you yeah your old man - what about this
guy oh there's one fit guy ooh look at
that
fauna and flora wait fauna is animals
Flora's plants sorry I'm stupid huh I'm
stupid unless I got that wrong then I'm
even stupider I don't know I've never
really checked up on what flora and
fauna are well obviously Flora's plants
with fauna alright nevermind em narrow
movin on
alright ready oh it's about hit 100%
vegetation go go vegetable yeah oh yeah
oh I'm the man okay let's get out of
here let's see what other Horrors await
us on another Island
fear
yep same cutscene are these lazy
developers alright let's go ooh ah it's
blue I like blue
all right oh it's it's winter they're
not fighting back tire my no no where is
blue me riccati duck me la la la semana
beer kappa da rocha para Zamani
bekata fire spreads life the Redwoods
giant redwood no giant sequoias need
fires to survive they almost went
extinct because of how well we were
putting out fires and 30 or so years
later they almost went extinct after we
started the fire service to put out
forest fires we didn't know why until we
realize that it was our own fault
whoa what was that oh oh I knew those
were bad oh no oh no oh well that's cool
but oh no this thing is like what is it
doing
what is that okay pick it up nope
I don't know what that is but I don't
like it and there's all the sudden like
this came out of nowhere I don't know
why
what whoa whoa whoa oh whoa
I get it oh that is cool Wow all right
okay got a nice little nest of these
water plants um I'll go away I know what
you're talking about uh so it seems okay
I'll send people to here go in the
desert needs water
thank you so much all right Oh
hey that's something
what's this power sent people here you
can figure it out guys
you're smart maybe go kite man go for
kite lady sorry it's hard to tell from a
distance don't judge me
alright go go go hopefully nothing bad
happens over here move explosive trees
oh no oh that's what those are oh no oh
boy that's bad
Oh village surrounded by explosive trees
yeah I hope I can move them all these
poor people they've been drowned they've
been burned alive now they're gonna be
exploded into pieces oh man I feel bad
for them man you know with me protecting
it like that I obviously don't do a very
good job
oh no no no guy guy oh lady that's bad
oh boy
oh I'm sorry about that sorry about that
alright hey I can eventually get these
out of here this water out here alright
oh yeah
lady I want to say that it's your own
fault I better get those moved all right
create and replant it on an impassable
wall oh okay oh I get it okay I get it I
get it I get it
I am smart I can understand the very
easy to understand instructions that
they're giving me all right here we go
all right plant these on this impassable
wall all right here come here
get over here it would be a very bad but
oh so tempting idea to plant a fire tree
right next to these I shouldn't I really
shouldn't
really really I shouldn't I should not
ah ah yeah oh [ __ ] I'm wasting them I'm
wasting them but can't resist boom oh
cool it's like fireworks all right
enough of that
look at these blown up boom boom all
that did nothing gimme this come here
not sand got air come here boom uh a
bang II no come on plant what the heck
is this no go away
come here I'm not you know what the heck
e heck not sand you make me angry
I want the fire - fine I'll get this
fire tree I don't need your fire boom
boom boom
almost got it alright can you make it
lady are you gonna are you okay you need
help oh oh wait what am i doing I can
amplify my breath oh so much water oh
that is morning
dump this up here come on come on get
this out of here get out of here
I don't even try a water please don't
cuz you're about to drown my disciple
huh boy
sorry it's her lady sorry about this I'm
afraid you're gonna not do well oh no oh
you got it did you get it yeah good job
now don't drown yes swim so Emma lady
swim all right I gotta cut it here thank
you guys again so much for watching I
appreciate each and every one of you and
I will see you guys in part 10 of let's
play from dust bye bye